this is a production of Cornell
University
okay well so we're getting to the end of
the Titan Titan exhibit we've had a lot
of fun and the sibling quorum
- we stinky that we've had on display
all week is gonna get planted today I
just found funny enough I just found a
label at the bottom of this pot that
guarantees that this pot will not break
for ten years
and I want to call the manufacturer and
find out if there's a warranty against
Titans or if that No nullifies the
warranty so all right so this is our
sibling quorum twee stinky this one
doesn't have a name yet because if you
didn't know already the tradition with
titan growers so we don't actually give
it a pet name until it actually blooms
but we're very hopeful this is gonna
bloom we've been telling people that
this this little bud in the middle
that's starting to swell we're fairly
certain is a flower bud so if all goes
well with a bit of luck we could have a
titan and another titan blooming and my
guess now is 4 to 6 months but you'll
have to check back on the blog because
it's hard to say at this stage and it
weighs about 55 pounds so I'm gonna try
not to get a workers comp claim and I
think this is just about right so this
is our Dani mall and remember we do name
these we give these pet names when they
bloom so now if you have any good names
write them down and we might do a boat
which is what we did when we named we
stinky Titans tend not to be dormant for
very long and if they stay wet it
probably will be even less time
flower that makes babies cry okay so we
have watered in our sibling plant - we
stinky and now we're just gonna have to
wait and see
probably everybody wants to know when
can I say for sure if this is a flower
and I really won't know until the the
bud emerges from the soil which I expect
to take a couple months and about a
month after that once it's about 30
inches tall we'll start to notice a
bulge in the middle and we're really
hoping for that I think we have a
reasonable expectation so maybe in two
to three months check the blog and we'll
let you know where things are at
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu